فديه رمضان جدل كل عام في السودان تضارب
في الارقام داخل مجمع الفقه الاسلامي نفسه
وبينه وعلماء اخرين
المجمع وهو المرجعيه الدينيه حدد مبلغ 600
جنيه قيمه فديه المفطر في رمضان ورغم ضعف
القيمه التي تعادل دولار واحدا الا ان
رايي دائره الفتوى بذات الهيئه اعتبر ان
مبلغ 300 جنيه كاف للفديه ليخرج بعد ذلك
علماء وشيوخ اخرون ليحددوا مبالغ اخرى غير
التي خرجت من المجمع احيا غدرناه ب 600
لان 600 هي بساوي ثمن الصاع اللي هو نصف
الصاع اللي هو فيه مدين
فهي هي وجبه مشبعه هذه احدى الوجبات
الشعبيه الشائعه في السودان سندوتش طعميه
سودانيه سعره 300 جنيه سوداني اي نصف
دولار تقريبا هذا مطعم شعبي لنتعرف اكثر
على وجبات اخرى قد تكون رخيصه عايزه اتعرف
على ارخص الوجبات عله في المطعم عندنا
الفاصولياء والرجله والبطاطس والملو ارخص
عندنا البلد ب 700 وعندنا اي حاجه عن اقل
هند ب 700 والاغلى الاغلى يعني عندنا ذي
الفراخ المشوي الفرقه كامله باربعه
كتضارب الارقام تباينت الاراء وسط الشارع
السوداني حول قيمه الفديه بين مجمع الفقه
وعلماء اخرين 600 جنيه تشتري كيلو دقيق
وكذلك ارز وانواع المحليه من البسكويت
والحلويات
مبلغ غير كافي وانا ما اعرف ان هذه
المجموعه هو الجهه المسؤوله والمخوله من
المسائل الشرعيه في السودان ومخونه والامر
فشيء طبيعي انه
عدد من شيوخ الدين والعلماء سارعوا الى
تفنيد القيمه التي حددها مجمع الفقه
الاسلامي ما اقل من الف جنيه
الوجبه بالنسبه للانسان الفقير في اليوم
فعلى هذا الاساس انا ارى انما ذهب اليه
الاخرون يعني ربما لا يكون يعني في حاله
المسكين او حاجه المسكين
الخلافات بين المرجعيات الدينيه حول قيمه
الفديه باتت امرا شبه معتاد بعضهم يتمسك
باقل ما يمكن ان يشبع الانسان بغض النظر
عن جودته والبعض الاخر يرى انها فرصه بان
يتذوق الفقير طعاما غير الذي اعتاد عليه
لين يعقوب العربيه الخرطوم